- Well, Alison, you're doing a guest role
on "Days of Our Lives".
So is this, I mean, you just had,
you were this character
for so long, right?
And then is it weird to go
back after all these years?
- Yeah, it started when I was 16.
I mean, I played
- Wow.
this character more than half of my life.
- Wait, just a minute, think about that.
Your boy is 16.
You have been this
character since you were,
can you imagine your kid?
I always think back to
like things like that,
and I'm like, oh my God.
- Oh my god, right,
at his age, this is how old
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- I was when I auditioned,
oh my gosh, I hadn't,
Kelly, I hadn't even thought of that.
Yes, I was his age
(man laughs)
when I auditioned to play this part.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I remember at the
time thinking it would be
like one day a week, you know,
kids on soap operas aren't on very often.
And I wasn't even supposed
to be acting anymore.
I had told my dad I
really should just stay
around casting directors,
you know, so don't forget me.
But he was really focused on my education
and wanted me to go to college.
And so he's sort of unwillingly
agreed to one more audition.
And it was for "Days
of Our Lives" (laughs).
And I got the job.
(Kelly laughs)
I can't imagine.
Oh my go--
- No, I know.
That's what I think about things,
like even me moving across
country on my own at 18
living on a mattress, in this
like nothing like little room.
Like I can't imagine
letting my kid do that.
Like there's things I did
that I'm like what?
- Right.
- Like, yeah,
but it's interesting,
- Yeah.
- like you've been there
since 16 years old.
And so is it,
- And I (indistinct)
- I heard you've been gone
for like--
- work on time
and know all my lines
- Yeah, yeah.
- and be responsible.
And you know, part of
growing up in this industry
is that kids, you know,
even if you're a kid, they don't care.
You have to know your lines,
you have to be prepared,
you have to do it again 70
times if that's what they say.
Like, I remember one director
telling me, you know,
my laugh wasn't realistic
enough when I was like eight.
I had this like fake laugh,
and he made, he was
not kidding by the way,
he didn't try to make me laugh for real.
Like he laid into me, and
I had to go into my trailer
and figure out how to laugh
fake but make it sound real.
And I was so,
I remember being terrified.
- Oh my gosh.
At eight?
- Like you better
get this right sweetie, pull it together.
Yeah.
- Yeah at eight,
nah, I was like, still like,
I was doing nothing like
what you were doing, wow.